after the rain there's a sense of quiet
resignation to work together to clean up
the streets the flood water is a
frequent unwelcome presence in their
homes these family members are wearing
clothes borrowed from relatives their
television isn't working their furniture
destroyed and their bedding and clothes
are ruined my little doyoung we are
traumatized it has happened so many
times just this month our things have
ruined the water came in so fast we
didn't have time to save them jakarta's
local governor is being criticized over
how his administration has handled this
year's floods advisors to the national
government say there was a lack of
preparation anger at the general what
has happened in the January floods was
such massive destruction we have early
warning systems to plan ahead for
example they should have dedicated land
for people to leave their cause so fewer
vehicles could have been damaged lawyer
as Asti Gordon Angola is leading a class
action on behalf of those affected by
floods in January when 66 people were
killed in flash flooding he says more
people may join the class action as the
floods continue there is no early
warning system we have the rainy season
all the time there should be more
preparation but nothing has changed
governor and SB Sweden says the city is
adequately prepared for the rainy season
and has been monitoring and clearing
gutters on homes and buildings as a
precaution but many say that's not
enough this is now a familiar routine
for people here self evacuating and then
coming back to assess the damage and at
least try to clean up this area has been
flooded at least five times this month
and there's more extreme weather coming
hundreds have sought shelter at a local
mosque after torrential rain some have
begun to return home but it won't be
long before they may need to leave again
more heavy rain and storms are forecast
until the beginning of next month
Jessica Washington al Jazeera Jakarta